[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en el espacio para hablar de la misión
China de exploración de martes día 91
que ya lleva alrededor de 500 días en el
planeta rojo y su explorador en rulom ha
recorrido casi 2.000 metros de
superficie marciana según los
responsables del proyecto el Rover ha
podido analizar con los cóncavos
cráteres y surcos en la zona donde
matizó revelando lo que aseguran es un
vínculo significativo entre la formación
de crestas y actividad de agua líquida
hace unos mil millones de años
el color de las rocas Es realmente
brillante
al analizar los datos del espectro
descubrimos que es una especie de sal
llena de minerales que contienen agua
conecta las partículas del suelo y
después de la compresión forman una roca
tan laxa 100 años
podemos especular que la atmósfera era
adecuada para originar vida o que las
condiciones climáticas en Marte eran
favorables hace mil millones de años
esas condiciones podrían existir a un
bajo tierra en un espacio relativamente
templado
el 15 de mayo de 2021 el Rover Girón se
posó en su área de amartizaje
preseleccionada en utopia planicia una
extensa llanura marciana donde se
realizó la exploración que también ha
arrojado datos sobre la relación entre
la densidad de rocas en Marte y la
erosión de la superficie Además del
campo de gravedad del planeta rojo
actualmente el explorador se encuentra
en hibernación mientras las condiciones
atmosféricas de marte mejoran Pues el
pasado 20 de septiembre el equipo
responsable recibió en París el premio
mundial del espacio el galardón
aeroespacial Internacional más
importante que fue otorgado por la
federación astronáutica internacional
por su papel para inspirar y liderar una
mayor exploración de Marte
vamos ahora hasta Nigeria para conocer
una aplicación de transporte compartido
que busca darle seguridad a las mujeres
por eso solo cuenta con mujeres
conductoras se llama hair right y fue
lanzada en 2022 tras numerosas denuncias
de agresiones sexuales y de acoso a
pasajeras y conductoras
no queremos casos en los que las mujeres
tengan que estar alerta o el límite
cuando utilizan servicios de transporte
compartido entonces hair right está ahí
para britar alternativas más seguras
para las mujeres además si miras las
estadísticas alrededor del mundo hay muy
pocas mujeres que sean conductoras en
las plataformas de transporte compartido
significa que se puede identificar y
Resaltar las barreras que impiden que
las mujeres ingresen a la industria de
la movilidad por eso queremos crear
oportunidades inclusivas para las
mujeres
la aplicación inició sus servicios con
10 conductoras y en su primer mes
funcionando en abuya la capital del país
se registraron aproximadamente 500
viajes la plataforma tiene como objetivo
expandirse a otras ciudades y cuenta con
un sistema en el que las pasajeras
también son evaluadas a su vez las
usuarias del servicio aseguran que le
encuentran numerosos beneficios
he tenido experiencias aterradoras de
las otras aplicaciones a veces los
conductores tienen conversaciones
innecesarios contigo o la forma como
están vestidos parecen Por supuesto que
te asustarás porque son hombres y
sientes que quieren atacarte o algunas
conversaciones incómodas que están
teniendo contigo donde están tratando de
volverse innecesariamente personales Y
uno se pregunta por qué aunque en
Nigeria no hay cifras oficiales de
denuncias por acosos o abusos en las
plataformas de transporte las
responsables de hair right explican que
estas historias son comunes casi
semanalmente en la ciudad por lo que
pidan una mayor atención de las
autoridades
vamos a hablar ahora de una iniciativa
que busca descarbonizar la industria de
los vinilos musicales Pese a que las
plataformas de streaming han conquistado
a millones de personas en el mundo hay
cientos de miles de consumidores de
vinilos musicales y los compradores han
crecido considerablemente en la última
década pues este proyecto lleva cuatro
años desarrollando una alternativa al
policloruro de vinilo comúnmente
conocido como PVC sin que se alteren ni
la maquinaria ni los procesos de
producción existentes
llevamos cuatro años de investigación y
desarrollo y empezamos con biopolímero a
base de azúcar encontramos rellenos
orgánicos y colorantes orgánicos
entonces logramos una receta única la
industria de la música y las artes
creativas deberían estar a la vanguardia
de la innovación Por supuesto que
deberían y típicamente el cambio
cultural es lo que afecta el cambio
político y social existe un grupo
llamado music
lo que traduce literalmente la música de
Clara emergencia
artistas profesionales de la música y
organizaciones que buscan ejercer
presión ambiental para que la industria
musical ejerza su influencia y ayuda a
mitigar la crisis climática para ellos
esta es una iniciativa clave
esencialmente lo que tenemos ahora es un
producto libre de culpa pueden
imaginarse si pudiéramos crear otros
productos libres de culpa sabíamos cuál
es el problema la producción de vinilos
es tóxica en muchos sentidos y hay todo
tipo de procesos que dañan el medio
ambiente involucrados pero nos encantan
los vinilos Cuál fue la solución
encontrar una forma no tóxica de
hacerlos los responsables piden una
mayor difusión y aseguran que la
industria vivirá una importante
transformación en cuanto los artistas
empiecen a usar este material en sus
productos así llegamos al final de este
espacio a ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía los invitamos a repetir este y
otros programas en nuestra web Franz
24.com
[Música]